she says something when I said that you
would do it what'd you say just tell him
what you said
so Smallville came at a time when I was
a teenager in high school experimenting
with my sexuality so I admitted to Bobby
that I very furiously and very
frequently masturbated to you so I'm
sorry I had to that's for you to come on
Willy but you don't know I always got
like the the the you know I I was always
appreciative but like you know my
following was like goth chicks
yeah Smiths fans and I love that yeah so
that was always me I was the freaky dark
weird misunderstood now tell me this
because you know Smallville came when it
was the internet hadn't really like
exploded was it a lot you really did I
was you know never to Tom yeah never I
always wanted sort of like the you know
the the flawed bad guy kind of that's
why I'm with Bobby now I never liked the
super you know you like real people who
are flawed who will just say it as it is
did you like you stuck it inside I don't
even want to ask a little bit she just
got my they broke up but you know
Filipinos tell it like it is
oh yeah my Filipino stepping on the
first time I met her I go hey Michael
and her name coincidentally was Lex nice
to meet you how are ya you know I have
diarrhea and the next I was like so
Michael are you gay yeah why would you
say that
single yeah yeah but I said that when
you did park there I go
how are you married yeah you did ask me
a girlfriend did you hate and you felt
sad for yourselves gonna be like Pauly
Shore yeah I just know but stop don't do
that it's because of the fact that I
adore this guy I really do and I I don't
want to I don't want him to become
somebody that's just like in his 60s
never had children but as if you can't
live a fully fulfilled life I am looking
for oh you are okay I'm dating I
understand your argument I used to like
20s and 30s you know but I would say
this he this [ __ ] right here he's not
a closer
he's not about your sexualities question
yeah who knows maybe he's like more
maybes banging tons of people we don't
know nope George you're a good dude
don't know but I just want to say that
so that he doesn't feel hurt he's not
really a good dude I'm just saying that
yeah I'm a liar yeah yeah yeah but I got
you know I got a [ __ ] machine though I
don't like I used to go out all the time
I used now I'm exhausted I'm 44 years
old I'm like work and I like to have
friends over we karaoke yeah over yeah
yeah but I don't like I used to go out I
gotta wait I want to meet girls and it's
just exhausting now you have your phone
and you know it's just it's just a lot
so much gas just a lot yeah oh now I
just try to like I try to find someone I
can enjoy my life with so I definitely I
have been dating I'm not gonna say much
more than that don't have too much I
don't need to say anything yeah alright
good also I'm mildly stalk your
Instagram and it's because you have a
dog and dogs give you so much love yeah
doesn't incentivize
you as much to go out and go [ __ ]
hunting because you have a kind of love
at home and honestly I could live with
my animals my whole life alone without
this [ __ ]
yeah with four animals I think I'm
fulfilled really yeah I mean that's why
I'm dude let me see something right now
before my girlfriend I hated animals I
think we all hate ourselves in a way
yeah there's not one person in this room
that probably doesn't hate themselves a
little bit yeah but I yeah I'm I'm
self-conscious about my areola size yeah
what is your head was there it's pretty
it's like a silver dollar pancake you
can't hate yourself it's you know I have
large balls for when I was when I was
younger I remember I looked at my
grandfather Lou and he had this giant
bulge in his slacks and I look like that
I'm telling my brother and I Eric he was
looking at her like do you what's up
with Titus yeah but then I remember my
daddy was my dad's real private we're
driving back home from New York and I'm
like hey why are grandpa lose balls so
big you asked some respect your
grandfather and he just has these giant
testicles and then I got really worried
and I cried to my dad I go dad why I
think my balls are big they wasn't he
wasn't but my balls aren't like that oh
they're not like that big though no I
mean I have good sized balls because you
showed us kind of a little bit it's not
you ever accidentally sit on them no
they're not that big and they're not
that big I do the ball buckle routine I
used to do
[Music]